an anti-semitic bigot murdered 11 and
injured six Jews worshiping at a
Pittsburgh synagogue on Saturday the
media are blaming Donald Trump the
shooter hates Donald Trump and Donald
Trump wants to kill the shooter we will
analyze the case for the death penalty
then Barack Obama reminds us why we
forgot about him Hillary Clinton gets
ready for 2020 and the Simpsons kill op
who if I hadn't stopped watching The
Simpsons 20 years ago I would totally
stop watching them now
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today a lot of
horrible news maybe some silver lining
if you can think about some of the
justice that maybe we'll be able to get
out of this but really really tough news
cycle so before we delve into all of it
let's make a little bit of money honey
let's welcome to my boudoir you are in
my boudoir right now because I am on the
road I'm in Huntsville Alabama we'll be
speaking tonight at the University there
and so you're seeing this bit now this
bed that I've got behind me it's not
it's not the top notch if you want the
top notch you've got to get purple
mattress I've told you about purple
mattress it is it has revolutionized my
life
it has preserved my marriage from
divorce I got the California king this
thing is the best bed I've ever slept on
it is not like a an innerspring it is
not like memory foam it is completely
new it was developed by a rocket
scientist it's somehow is both firm and
soft at the same time I know that sounds
like a contradiction it actually is it
cradles your body perfectly I actually
do have back trouble it runs in my
family my whole family does I have been
sleeping better I have been feeling
better it is so good I cannot recommend
this mattress enough right now my
listeners will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a purple mattress
that's don't say I never did nothing for
you right now that and they've got a lot
of other great free gifts on the website
text qoph fa ce o-- v fe f e - 47 47 47
that is the only way to get this free
pillow
you've got to text do it right now pull
over I don't care where you are text go
if FA CoV f EF e - 47 47 47 that is co
the fe fe - 47 47 47 okay let's jump
right into this news cycle
there was this horrific shooting over
the weekend this was the largest scale
attack on Jews in American history
apparently there were 11 people killed
six people wounded it was at the
synagogue in Pittsburgh and the guy was
he's not a lunatic I mean I he's
probably got to be a little bit loony to
do anything like this but this guy is an
out-and-out anti-semitic bigot he's
written about this he's posted all
social media about this right now the
website gab GA B which is the non
censoring Twitter is under fire because
they don't censor people so this guy was
on it and that's what happens when you
don't censor people bad guys you know
say their point of view that doesn't
mean that when you don't censor people
people you know will go out and commit
crimes it also doesn't mean that when
you censor people people won't commit
crimes obviously the two are not related
the speech in the act or categorically
different but gab is under fire for this
I mean this guy had a plan
this guy had a perverse ideology he went
out and he did it so what are the media
doing there immediately blaming Donald
Trump
they've been blaming Trump and
Republicans now for a couple weeks
because there was that wacko down in
Florida who was mailing the pipe bombs
and so now they're blaming Trump for
this guy - it is worth pointing out this
guy apparently despised Donald Trump he
didn't vote for Donald Trump he posted
on social media he said I've never voted
for Donald Trump I've never owned a mag
a hat I have never touched a mag a hat I
don't like him because Trump likes Jews
too much apparently and this is another
aspect of the story that's been lost by
the media which is that this
administration is the most Pro Jewish
administration probably in American
history apparently that was part of this
guy's gripe with him is that you know
Donald Trump first of all Donald Trump's
daughter converted to Judaism Donald
Trump's son-in-law is Jewish he put his
son-in-law and daughter-in-law in charge
apparently of Middle Eastern policy or
of trying to resolve the
israel-palestine conflict he obviously
followed through on a long-standing
promise of American presidents that no
one had ever followed through on Donald
Trump moved the US Embassy in Israel to
Jerusalem which is the capital of Israel
they built a train station for the guy
in Jerusalem there's a Donald Trump
train station so I think the media
turning us in trying to say that somehow
the Republican Party were conservatives
or Donald Trump or anti-semitic that is
insane
however the reason that they can get
away with it is that this shooter was
anti-immigrant they're saying he's
anti-immigrant and conservatives want to
limit some immigrants some conservatives
want to limit immigration all Americans
virtually all Americans
want to stop illegal immigration because
it's obviously against our laws in a
violation of the country so see he's
anti-immigrant they they don't want an
illegal immigration see they're the same
it's really cynical and it's really
gross but that's how they get away with
it because there is that aspect to this
guy's ideology such as it was his
ideology really is just bigotry and
racial hatred but President Trump I
thought responded pretty well to this
and he's getting a lot of pushback even
though I thought this the response was
exactly great which is that we need to
sab this guy this guy needs to be
executed by the state as they a carriage
of justice through capital punishment
here's Donald Trump I think one thing we
should do is we should stiffen up our
laws in terms of the death penalty when
people do this they should get the death
penalty and they shouldn't have to wait
years and years now the lawyers will get
involved anybody that does a thing like
this to innocent people that are in
Temple or in church we had the so many
incidents with churches they should
really suffer the ultimate price they
should pay the ultimate price I felt
that way for a long time absolutely
right this is absolutely right and it's
shocking to me that people on the left
and the right or disagreeing with it the
case for the death penalty has never
been stronger
and yet I hear a even your conservatives
say I pose the death penalty I was on a
panel at politican Charlie Kirk was
sitting next to me I liked Charlie a lot
but he he says I oppose the death
penalty because I'm pro-life and I just
don't think this argument is very strong
the case for the death penalty has never
been stronger especially now that we
have technological advances that can
exonerate people who have been wrongly
accused especially that we have
technological advantage that can put
perpetrators and convicts we can place
them at the scene of the crime we can
know that they were there with relative
certainty the case has never been
stronger but our culture right now is so
confused and we don't have a vocabulary
to talk about moral issues so we say you
know pro-life that's the slogan but of
course this is not a precise way of
talking about things it's the same with
torture you know I think people hear
death penalty and because we have a
feelings first culture they say Oh death
is bad so I'm against death so
no death death is bad because it doesn't
sound doesn't feel good the same with
torches I'm Against Torture as though
this is some morally clear position to
hold but that isn't the case you know
just just to use the example of torture
the reason that we don't torture enemy
soldiers is well it's because we've all
agreed to something called the Geneva
Conventions but the purpose of that the
reason that we don't torture enemy
soldiers is to protect civilians in
times of war that's why we don't torture
enemy soldiers as we say look if you
won't attack civilians if you won't
target civilians in times of war we will
give you certain protections certain
pleasantries you you know you won't be
tortured you won't be detained in this
way you will you'll have this this
aspect of justice okay fine so some
people want to extend that and say that
we shouldn't torture terrorists but that
of course undermines the entire case for
the Geneva Conventions that undermines
the entire case for not torturing
soldiers because terrorists by
definition target civilians to advance
their political agenda so if we start
extending Geneva Convention protections
to terrorists we undermine the whole
purpose of the Geneva Convention we
undermine the whole purpose of saying if
you don't target civilians we won't do
certain things to you will give you
certain pleasantries if we start
offering that to everybody then there is
no incentive and more civilians are
gonna die and more civilians are gonna
get hurt it's the same thing with the
death penalty he's right now in we
always focus when you talk about
criminal justice criminal justice reform
we talk about rehabilitating criminals
say that's the purpose you know they go
to jail they go to prison to be
rehabilitated and that's true
there is a rehabilitative purpose of
punishment and of the justice system but
that's not the only purpose that's not
the only aspect of justice there are at
least two others in probably three
there's retribution
there's retributive justice punishing
people because they did the crime
there's rehabilitation there's
deterrence you can try to deter further
crimes and then there's defending
society from the criminals who have
committed these acts Adam Smith great
economist and great moral philosopher
said mercy to the guilty is cruelty to
the
innocent when we're talking about States
and criminal justice systems so you'll
hear I was at a school the other night
in August Anna University in South
Dakota and someone said you shouldn't
you oppose the death penalty it's more
expensive to pursue the death penalty
than to pursue life in prison I said
okay who cares who cares so it's I mean
and he's right by the way between 1989
and 1997 the cost of pursuing the death
penalty against somebody was about
quarter of a million dollars from the
beginning of the trial to zapping him it
was about a quarter of a million dollars
between 1998 and 2004 that number jumped
to about six hundred twenty six hundred
twenty-one thousand dollars as the
median so that is a huge increase it's
more than doubled okay fine
drop in the bucket doesn't really matter
also we don't execute that many people
which is part of the problem of this
debate so we don't with so far this year
I think that in various states we've
executed 18 people seven more are set to
be executed this year it looks likely
that only six more will be executed so
you're looking at 24 or two per month
the majority of death sentences are not
carried out in the United States since
1973 16 percent of people who have been
sentenced to death have actually been
executed so 84 percent have not been
executed and of the people who remain on
death row they've not been pardoned
they've not been had their convictions
overturned they've not had this or that
or the other thing a full 75 percent of
them or have not been executed only 25
percent who remain on death row have
been executed so there is an aspect of
this which might be cruel and unusual
punishment but it's not the death
penalty the that's another argument that
people try to make they say it's cruel
and unusual absolutely not it's been
carried out by every government for all
of human history everywhere at the time
of the ratification of the Constitution
when we were talking about cruel unusual
punishment everywhere had the death
penalty it was virtually the definition
of a felony now life in prison might be
cruel and unusual it might be cruel and
unusual to sentence someone to death and
then have them waiting for 30 years
languishing they've already made peace
with dying but but there there's a
little the glimpse of Hope or this or
I mean that might be maddening that
might be cruel and unusual I can totally
understand getting rid of that but we
shouldn't oh we shouldn't speak in a
confused way about the death penalty
there are many good purposes for it so
we know it does deter crime by the way
there have been studies about this since
1968 general deterrence theory but then
studies in the 1970s even recent studies
that show that the death penalty deters
crime and in places where it's shown not
to deter crime very much one likely
cause of that is that the death penalty
isn't actually carried out so it's
deterrent effect isn't very strong but
we know in places where the death
penalty has carried out quickly where
it's carried out swiftly that the
deterrent effect is significantly
stronger so it does have that as a
defensive society obviously by
definition it defends society because
you're taking the criminal and you're
setting up a meeting with his maker only
god can judge but we can arrange the
meeting and then finally there is
retribution there you know when when the
terrorists killed 3,000 Americans on
September 11 2001 President Bush sat in
the Oval Office he spoke to the American
people and he said these attacks fill us
with horror with great sadness and with
a quiet unyielding anger that unyielding
anger it might be expressed in a couple
ways it might be expressed because we
just want a little revenge fine but
that's not what retribution retributive
punishment does
we also are angered because of the in
justice of that and what retribution and
retributive punishment does is not gets
revenge but it corrects the error the
the miscarriage of justice it goes some
way toward restoring a balance of
justice more on this in a second but
first we've got to thank another another
sponsor and make a little money honey
and I can feed you we have got blue
apron oh how I miss blue apron I've been
on the road for a week now I've been
just living in the gutter eating fast
food and it's gross and I feel fat and
horrible I can't wait to get home and
eat my blue apron blue aprons mission is
to make incredible home cooking
accessible to everyone you can make
dinner in as little as twenty minutes
even if you're me you know even if
you're a guy who doesn't cook very much
you can do it very quickly they sent
top-quality ingredients it is as good as
anything you're gonna get a lot better
than what I would get when I would go to
the grocery store and they send you
these cool recipes that are always
changing so you're not gonna get sick of
anything you're not gonna be repeating
recipes and then what's also pretty nice
is that once you make it you know you
have the dinner you like it you just
keep the recipe and you put it in your
cookbook so blue apron is gonna move on
there chefs are gonna create lots of new
recipes and you can keep that one for
you know for whenever your blue apron
runs out and then you know you can keep
making those recipes a huge range of
them bursting with flavor check out this
week's menu don't say I never did
nothing for you get three meals free
blue apron calm slash cough FA CE o VF e
fe that is blue apron calm / co f f/a co
v fe fe have a little nice beaker of
coffe fa while you're eating it sets off
blue apron very well blue apron a better
way to cook so there are all of these
different arguments for the death
penalty don't let anybody tell you that
it's wrong or that it's immoral you know
to look at those people who were slain
in Pittsburgh worshipping because a
bigot because a wicked evil bigot came
in there and slaughtered them in cold
blood in the house of God while they
were praying one feels a quiet
unyielding anger and one feels in need
to in any way restore a balance of
justice we also want to protect society
we also want to deter the further acts
and I hope that this guy can get
rehabilitated while he's waiting to hang
because it will be very good for his
soul I don't care that much I'm much
more interested in the other aspects of
justice on this but he should hang and
it should be swift and if we're going to
have criminal justice reform the first
thing we should reform is reinstituting
that justice because our current death
penalty regime is not particularly just
obviously the media or blaming Donald
Trump this has been going on for a long
time those those pipe bombs sent by the
worst bomber ever this Looney tune
ex-stripper from Florida the media were
referring to those bombs as Trump
targets bombs say so yes bombs were sent
to Trump
targets as though you know Donald Trump
was there mailing the packages
themselves you know that this creates a
big issue
I mean look they're even doing it with
this guy who shot all those people in
the synagogue and they're saying they're
trying to connect him in some way to
Trump even though he hated Trump and
Trump hates him and wants to kill him we
should not do this in our political
rhetoric it's a really bad idea and and
I'll point out that Donald Trump is
pretty reckless sometimes in the way he
speaks
he actually hasn't really been reckless
on this and he explains it when the left
has committed lunatic fringe acts of
violence the right has not really
exploited it here he is explaining the
difference yet when a Bernie Sanders
supporter tried to murder congressional
Republicans and severely wounded a great
man named Steve Scalise and others we
did not use that heinous attempt at mass
murder for political gain because that
would have been wrong it would have been
the wrong thing to do that's right that
would have been the wrong thing to do
it's the right thing to do to remind
them that you did the right thing
because you won't get credit for doing
the right thing unless you tell them
that you did the right thing
which is a little boastful and might
seem like the wrong thing but it is the
right thing I assure you but this is
absolutely right you don't want to take
these fringy lunatic examples and try to
pretend that they're representative of
the whole group that is what the left
does and so you'll you know we've been
talking about left-wing violence all
over this country but we're not talking
about the Congressional baseball game
guy we're talking about the mobs of
people who have gone out into the street
threatened conservatives harassed them
assaulted them gone to their homes were
their children's sleep and and further
we weren't even really talking about
that too much we didn't talk about
antiva a whole lot until the elected
Democrat leaders encouraged all of it
and not just one of them
not even just Maxine Waters but Waters
Holder Booker Hillary Clinton all of
them they're trying to take they're
trying to equate one radical fringe guy
who did something
evil thing and not talk about it as evil
per se which it is but try to pain to
conservatives or right-wingers or
Republicans that way whereas on the left
it is the mainstream that they have to
answer for this is also one of the truly
awful aspects of identity politics which
is that in the United States after the I
don't know 1960s 1970s there really
wasn't a much of a white racial
consciousness in American politics it
had really been wiped away the u.s. had
gone a long way over the course of about
a hundred years 1860 to 1970s to wipe
away the sins of slavery and the d'azur
inequalities and discriminations that
were wrought by those systems and there
wasn't really a white racial
consciousness and there were there were
some fringe writers who actually called
for one they said we need a white racial
consciousness and people said no
absolutely not we reject identity
politics but then the left has forced a
white racial identity which is which is
unfortunate because by embracing
identity politics as their means of
ascent as their means of consolidating
political power on the Left they have
forced a white racial identity it only
only makes sense if you're going to try
to say that we have a what is it a
coalition of the ascendant you've got
all of these people and you're
explicitly appealing to their skin color
or to their ethnic heritage or whatever
and you're uniting them by saying that
there's a common enemy in what now we
jokingly referred to as the straight
white male the straight white cisgender
male the straight white which is an
absurd term that I try not to use the
straight white male who thinks that he's
a male or whatever if that is the
personification of evil then you're
going to create an identity around those
groups you've you've done it the left
has done it we didn't do it we didn't
paint this guy is the worst guy on earth
or that color or this woman or this
gender or whatever we didn't paint that
as the personification of evil but the
left in order to assemble their identity
politics coalition had to do that and as
a result you see
a white racial consciousness or
male-male sexual consciousness I don't
know it's pretty stupid it isn't good
when the left does it it isn't good when
the right does it but the left is going
to make it inevitable the left is going
to force this to be inevitable and that
is a really ugly and put blame lies
there so if we're going to stop identity
politics which I strongly encourage
everybody's got to do it otherwise
otherwise it is simply going to grow it
is only going to fester it's only going
to get worse and it is a zero-sum game
it is truly gutter politics and they're
they're gonna keep it up I mean you know
it talked about the the Bernie bro guy
we're not talking about the Bernie bro
as the main they've got one who shot up
the Congressional baseball game we're
not talking about that is the mainstream
of the Democratic Party but the New York
Times is and the New York Times just
last week published assassination porn
published this novelist alleged novelist
that I've never read any of her works
obviously Zoe sharp who wrote a whole
piece fantasizing about the Secret
Service assassinating Donald Trump that
wasn't published on gab that wasn't
published on some fringe social media
wacky board that was published in the
New York Times and that that is a huge
distinction there isn't a moral
equivalence here and you've got to be
able to do it
it requires moral clarity I know that it
is insane to suggest that Donald Trump
playboy for 30 years you know tabloid
legend somehow has some moral clarity
here but he does when you see an act of
evil like the shooting of that synagogue
you've got to kill that guy by the arm
of the state because of justice justice
demands that many kinds of justice
demand men when you see these heinous
identity politics and ideologies that
come from that you've got to call it out
for what it is
and you've got to reject it you've got
to reject it full-throated Lee
wholeheartedly not just for one guy not
just for one group but for everybody you
know in speaking of the fringes versus
the mainstream Barack Obama he's out on
the campaign trail again and he is
perfectly identifying this distinction
because he is out there calling Donald
Trump a shameless liar here he is you
know when I'm talking to Michelle
sometimes I'm not like all honey man did
you see I did all the dishes you know
and she's all like yeah but that's like
the first time you've done that in a
week what's what you do wrong and I said
well we all do that to some degree right
I mean it's human nature but what we
have not seen before in our recent
public life at least is politicians just
blatantly repeatedly boldly shamelessly
like making stuff up calling up them
calling doctors that you can't keep
doctors that you can keep calling
terrorist attacks in our consulate in
Benghazi a spontaneous response to a u2
oh wait a minute no we have seen all of
that from you from you you shameless
cynical leftist hack Chicago machine
oily every time he opens his mouth
Donald Trump gets 10,000 votes that's
how it works I can't wait I hope the
NRCC the NRS see the RNC all the GOP all
of the conservative institutions are
paying Barack Obama's speaker fees
because every time he opens his mouth we
get a lot closer to winning in the
midterms and in the 2020 election by the
way I just like to make a point people
always talk about have Barack Obama what
a what a rhetorician oh he's the
greatest orator since Pericles Oh what
wonderful soaring speeches from Barack
Obama compared to Donald Trump who can't
even spell on Twitter first of all I was
never horribly impressed by well I
wasn't maybe I was horribly impressed
but I was never I never terribly much
admired a president Trump's speeches
with one or two exceptions but listen
how he opened that is you know the guy
who apparently possesses this
tremendously advanced in superior
command of the English language he opens
up he says you know and sometimes I'm
all like blah blah blah blah blah and
then Michelle she's all like blah blah
blah like speaking like a little
millennial girl and I'm like and then
she was like and then he was like
and I feel like just totally feel like
lalalalala but obviously the the essence
of this is absurd because when you
compare Barack Obama's lies to Donald
Trump's lies there is no comparison they
are utterly different he's saying that
Donald Trump shamelessly lies
shamelessly he is he has exaggerated the
truth I'm willing to say that you said a
couple things that quite literally are
not true you know what what does he do
he exaggerate sack roud size every now
and again he exaggerated s' this I mean
he's been doing this whole career it's
huge it's gonna be the biggest the
greatest okay that's that is what Donald
Trump does his lies are exaggerating how
many people came to his rally by the way
I took tens of thousands a hundred
thousand people come to his rallies and
he exaggerated sit by ten thousand and
they call it a lie what are Barack
Obama's lies like they're like hey you
can't keep your doctor like like like
you know and I'm like and he's like
those are those are what those lies
aren't like he says that you can keep
your doctor then he opens a sixth of the
US economy and you can't keep your
doctor he says that an attack on our
consulate was caused by some poor guy
who made a YouTube video we're a little
YouTube video that nobody saw in reality
it was Islamic terrorists in a
pre-planned premeditated attack on
September 11th September 11 2011 versus
wait 2012 2012 but those are totally
different given me the guy who lies
about the crowd sighs any day of the
week another another great lie that
Barack Obama told is he said in an
interview he said that Donald Trump will
never be President you'll never be
President Donald it was the best lie he
ever told I'm actually quite a fan of of
that lie cuz he got that one wrong if
you know okay I guess if we had to have
a liar as president I guess I'm glad he
was wrong about that but broadly
speaking a lot of this comes because the
left has not let reality dawn on them
they're still running around in these
fantasies Barack Obama is still going
out there pretending that he is a
rockstar pretending that it's 2006-2007
you know before he even ever ran that
he's the rock star compare the crowd
sizes that Obama gets to the people that
Donald Trump gets how many orders of
magnitude smaller is the Obama crowd
than the Donald Trump crowd they're
still
these fantasies like people haven't
caught on and the perfect example of
this the you know in a tough news cycle
really something that could give us all
hope that can give us a little little
smile a little joy is former future
president Hillary Clinton planning out
2020 here she is well I'd like to be
President okay I I think hopefully when
we have a Democrat in the oval office in
January of 2021 there's going to be so
much work to be done I mean we have
confused everybody in the world
including ourselves and we have confused
our friends and our enemies they have no
idea what the United States stands for
what we're likely to do what we think is
important so the work would be work that
I feel very well prepared for having
been in the Senate for eight years
having been a diplomat in the State
Department and it's just going to be a
lot of heavy lifting are you feeling oh
I have no idea Kara but I'm going to you
know I'm not gonna even think about till
we get through this November 6th
election about what's gonna happen after
that well I'm not gonna think about it
oh well we are ill er II don't worry
we're gonna think about it right now and
we go to the ballot box on November 6th
I love how she opens it she says well
you know I would like to be President
you don't say are you Hill or Hillary
Clinton the girl who has been in
politics since she was 12
the girl who dis basically launched her
campaign to run for president when she
graduated from Wellesley the woman who's
run now for president on two separate
occasions and really ran as her
husband's co-president so another to
occasion you want to be President
Hillary I'm shocked to hear that the
really telling aspect of this is when
she says we've confused everybody we've
confused our friends we've confused our
allies we've confused our enemies yes
you have yes you did that I think that
was a Freudian slip where you say one
thing but mean your mother I think she
certainly has confused a lot of people
but it's the left that it's confused
them just use that line we've confused
our allies and our friends the the Obama
administration well Hillary Clinton was
Secretary of State can whew
our enemy in Iran as a friend confused
him is afraid a so they sent pallets of
cash they allowed Iran to humiliate our
sailors they gave them the keys to a
future nuclear weapon that's not all all
the while abandoning our ally in Israel
all the while funding a campaign
opponents a fund sending operatives over
to try to unseat the Prime Minister of
Israel an awful relationship with them
how confusing is it when the Democrats
have been running for the last two years
about Donald Trump's collusion with the
Russians and yet during the entirety of
the Obama administration the u.s. went
soft on the Russians the u.s. joked that
Barack Obama made fun of Mitt Romney for
saying that Russia was an adversary he
said well met the cold war of the 1980s
called they want their foreign policy
back uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
Barack Obama uh uh the you know how
about when Hillary Clinton signed off to
sell uranium to Russian interests how
about that and now we're now I'm quite
confused you're absolutely right now
we're supposed to believe that Saudi
Arabia is the worst government on planet
earth and yet during the the Obama
administration Saudi Arabia was donating
millions and millions of dollars to the
Clinton Foundation I'm very confused you
are also very confused Hillary and
fortunately we've got a little bit of
clarity coming out now and we're tweet
treating our friends as our friends and
our enemies as our enemies this is
really important and that what a
distinction what a perfect way to
explain the difference between now and
then between the the Trump
administration and the Obama
administration or before that the
Clinton administration they're the
campaign's are zeroing in on this the
Trump campaign is a great ad out and we
will examine white is just right out of
the Ronald Reagan playbook while we're
living in the 80s again but we can't do
that until we go to daily wire calm we
got to check in on the caravan too got
to talk about the student Bill of Rights
so much more to get to go to daily wire
calm the main reason you've got to go to
daily wire calm right now is that my
speech is coming up tonight what time we
go I think we're going up at 7:30
Central time 8:30 Eastern time 5:30
Pacific time
I had a three in the morning Hawaii I
don't know I don't know how to do the
other time sounds it's gonna be tonight
5:30 Pacific 8:30 Eastern 7:30 central
go over there the topic will be how to
write nothing and sell 100,000 copies
I've never told my secret before I've
never told the secret to the number one
best-selling status of reasons to vote
for Democrats a comprehensive guide I
will go through it entirely through the
entire history of the wonderful system
that let me do all of that but you got
to go to daily wire.com why else you get
me you get the and reclaim and sure you
get the Ben Shapiro show you have to ask
questions in the mailbag get to ask
questions in the conversation that's
coming up none of that matters I've
nearly drowned because this is all I
have right now I have this little paper
cup full of coffee I don't even have
coffe FN here I just have coffee because
I left my left is tears tumblr back in
Los Angeles if I can make it back to the
west coast I will never be without it
again and and you're going to feel
exactly the same way when you get yours
it is the only fda-approved way of
protecting your leftist tears and it's
really important you know right now on
Mondays so on today subscribers get the
another Kingdom show so this is the show
that Andrew flavin wrote that I perform
all the roles in they get it on Mondays
non-members nonsubscribers have to wait
and they'll just get the audio on Friday
they don't get all the video it's not
cool get it because there is no better
way than relaxing on a nice Monday
kicking up your feet long day of work
you got your leftist here's tumblr
guzzling all those delicious leftist
tears turn on a little conservative or
at least non leftist entertainment
another Kingdom ooh you're gonna be
you're gonna be feeling snug as a bug in
a rug go over there right now we got a
lot more we'll be right back
so the Trump campaign for 2020 which is
now in year I know it seems like we only
focus it on the White House but there is
a trump presidential campaign as well
they have just released an ad that is
unoriginal it is entirely unoriginal and
it's excellent it is exactly what they
need to release right now it also tells
us a lot about their political strategy
let's check it out twenty-three thousand
net new jobs created when I look at the
way things are major it reminds me how
far we've come these numbers they are
depressingly we know the punch to the
gut survey we believe is growing even
more slowly than we thought things are
starting to change there's more
opportunity
and security to invest in the ones that
matter it only goes up from there it
only ends with violins playing and it's
obviously showing how much better things
are now does that look familiar does
that look familiar to you for though
probably not to you because I think the
median age of my audience is like two
and a half years old but for people for
the other part of the audience it's a
little older you probably remember that
from the 1984 Ronald Reagan campaign
here's Ronald Reagan's version
it's morning again in America today more
men and women will go to work than ever
before in our country's history
with interest rates at about half the
record highs of 1980 nearly 2000
families today will buy new homes more
than at any time in the past four years
this afternoon 6500 young men and women
will be married and it goes on and on
from there but you even hear the same
uplifting orchestral music just looking
at the economy just looking at how
things have improved it's morning in
America and Donald Trump is just
releasing his big ad thus far right
before the midterms it's morning in
America and that's the argument and this
is the argument by the way that
President Trump has been talking about
since 2015
I think people say he's reckless that
he's unpredictable you can never predict
him it actually turns out he's pretty
predictable and the reason we know this
is the guy looked back at the most
successful Republican presidential
administration and campaign in modern
history Ronald Reagan's and he has
copied it almost one for one
even the make America great again slogan
came from Ronald Reagan he puts a little
trumpian twist on it of course though
the Reagan one was let's make America
great again well and sure as the last
Trump drops that last he makes it an
imperative he says do it make America
great again ok that's fine
same exact idea same themes and now
we've got morning in America because
just like the Reagan administration
things have improved dramatically now
there's a difference here the the Trump
one you might call it higher energy in
part this is because our media have just
gotten much more frenzied so you know
the quality of the video the pacing of
the video people don't have attention
spans anymore people want to constantly
be hampt up ok that's part of it it's
also because our culture now is a little
more individualistic so you don't you
know at the you heard about halfway
through the morning in America Reagan
had people say more men and women are
going to get married today than ever
before and now we don't talk about that
because marriage is a bad thing and if
our popular culture I mean it's not
really it's actually a wonderful thing
I'd be living in the gutter without it
but now the culture is too
individualistic so you saw in that Trump
version of it it was a woman
she was a woman just doing it she was
the center she was the protagonist and
then her daughter became the protagonist
of the ad at the end
won its biggest president Trump wants to
appeal to women he wants to appeal in
particular to young people in part this
is a little bit of identity politics it
has become unfashionable to put old
white men in things this is you know as
we discussed before old white men are
the great enemy of the popular culture
so he focuses on that but it's the same
message it is applying that message to
the present day and you got to remember
that 1980 campaign from Reagan was a
huge campaign and it was a huge victory
and then what happened in 84 he won
every single state with the possible
exception of Minnesota I had I spoke to
a chief strategist on that campaign and
he insists that they won Minnesota too
but they didn't want to look like sore
losers but they more or less swept the
country and I think President Trump is
just counting on that you know he he's
ironically a pretty rational guy and the
campaign is at least being run pretty
rationally and I mean that in in so much
as when Donald Trump looks at what
issues to focus on he he just sort of
sees what issues people care most about
he's in a way that other conservatives
other Republicans didn't figure it out
he realizes people hate illegal
immigration why weren't it why wasn't
every Republican running on an extreme
position on him I don't know I can't
tell you why they felt that you couldn't
get away with it maybe that or the
culture was against them the media would
they were afraid of the media I don't
know President Trump isn't and and I
suspect this will be successful unless
of course the economy tanks and then you
know all is lost but it really does show
those parallels and it's really great
because I missed the 1980s so I'm glad
that I can live through it again all
right let's check back in on our Caravan
this crazy Caravan marching toward the
the us-mexico border do we have an image
of it I can hear all those Hondurans
traffic people across the border dooba
dooba dooba but-- i can't i always
whenever we hear counter caravan I just
think of that van Morris and so the good
news is it has been reduced in size so
it was up to 14 15,000 I think now
estimates are that it's around 7,000
people highly orchestrated a total stunt
by the left I mean you'd have to be
insane to think this were a spontaneous
uprising you probably also believed that
the attack on Benghazi was a spontaneous
response to a YouTube video we've got
the president of Honduras Juan Orlando
Hernandez admitting that this is an
orchestrated leftist stunt that it's not
spontaneous Judicial Watch has already
gone in and talked to some of these
people they've done an investigation and
it appears you know I think the way the
left wants to present this is its
mothers and babes just trying to come
over to freedom to get asylum to
whatever but there are a lot of bad
hombres in here Guatemalan authorities
have already recovered seven
unaccompanied minors who were just being
ferreted across by human smugglers by
human traffickers bad hombres could
really screw up for little kids lives
and this is what is being encouraged by
the left this is what the left is
applauding you know the way that
conservatives need to respond to this
I hope president Trump responds in this
way is to speak about this in
heart-tugging ly moral terms it's good
apparently general mattis as our
secretary mattis has approved plans to
send troops to the border a lot of
troops to the border but we need to
speak about this in really moral terms
Guatemalan authorities recover seven
unaccompanied minors who are being
brought across by human smugglers human
traffickers scum of the earth where bad
things can happen you know there was a
study by fusion I was reported in The
Huffington Post that 60 to 80 percent of
women
Amnesty International puts the number at
60% I think fusion puts it at 80% 60 to
80% of women and girls who were brought
across that border illegally or raped or
sexually assaulted that's what the left
is encouraging when the left is
encouraging illegal immigration when the
left encourages amnesty when the left
encourages not enforcing the law what
they are encouraging is for 60 to 80
percent of women and girls brought
across the border to be raped and
sexually assaulted it's as simple as
that I know that sounds harsh I know
that they don't intend for that nobody
wants women and girls to be raped but
when you support the policy you're
supporting the consequence of the policy
and the policy is in defensible once
again somehow magically miraculously the
Trump administration has great moral
clarity on this issue we've got to speak
of it this way all around you know
because people are seeing things in such
a narrow shallow way on the death
penalty on illegal immigration even on
the culture just before we go some
really sad news The Simpsons is killing
off a poo here to react we have a poo
[Music]
well we need you up ooh you might not
need the kwik-e-mart but we need you
know we don't really because people
don't watch The Simpsons anymore and
they probably haven't since the late
1990s The Simpsons work great though in
in its heyday The Simpsons was
absolutely terrific
they finally given in Matt Groening all
of these other guys who were behind The
Simpsons have resisted the calls to get
rid of a poo by radical lefty lunatics
who are offended on behalf of Indians
because you know it's not Indians who
are complaining about this it's decadent
white liberals who are complaining
it's little white girls complaining on
behalf of the subcontinent and saying oh
it's so offensive that a poo is a
stereotypical Indian character because
he says thank you come again and this is
considered offensive again by little
white girls on behalf of Indian people
for whom they do not speak but also if
we're going to get rid of stereotypical
characters in the Simpsons what happens
to all the other characters in the
Simpsons you know what happens to that
what Evans to the chief of police who is
this bumbling fat idiot who just eats
donuts all the time what happens to
groundskeeper Willie this scream and
angry violent Scotsman what happens to
the Italian chef who looks like he's a
Mario what happens to the mob boss who
portrays Italians as mobsters what
happens to the Jews what happens to
every other stereotype in the Simpsons
what happens to the the Latin American
guy in the bee costume I kind of forget
their names it's no a while since I've
seen it but there are these characters
Jewish character Mexican character
whatever what happens to them it's just
a poo it's just a poo right what is the
end game the end game here is the lowest
common denominator you know I had an
experience of this yesterday I I have
wonderful friends who are left-wing and
they're vegan and I've got I've actually
got multiple friends who are vegan okay
you know do what you want live the way
you want to live and so we're gonna go
get lunch and they took me to a vegan
restaurant now I'll point out when I
take my vegan friends to lunch I don't
take them to a barbecue restaurant but
so they take us to a vegan restaurant
and why why did they do it
we all eat vegetables we can all eat
bread right everybody could that's the
bare minimum of what you can eat so I
said okay well you can eat that we can't
eat meat but you can eat that so that's
fine this is the lowest common
denominator it's when somebody in your
family and your friends becomes a
vegetarian all of a sudden everybody's
got to become a vegetarian because oh
that's fine you can you don't need this
you don't need that you don't need me
you don't need cheese you don't and you
know by the way I I don't know anymore
masochistic cultural trend than veganism
so I could do vegetarianism for like a
week or two because at least you get
cheese and cream and alfredo sauce or
whatever you vegan if veganism is not
tenable it is I am deeply skeptical that
anybody is actually maintaining that
diet regimen nevertheless I digress it's
all this lowest common denominator
that's offensive to one person up who is
offensive to one person in the world so
we've got to get rid of him he brings
enjoyment to millions of people but one
person's offended so we got to get rid
of them the turkey sandwich is delicious
to billions of people on earth but one
person gets offended for the turkey I
guess the turkey is upset or something
so okay we got to get rid of nobody can
have it anymore what are we going to end
up with we're going to end up in a
perfectly clear white room with no
windows staring at a wall like this and
then someone's going to be offended that
it's a right white room so it's gonna
have to be a beige room or something and
all of the little diversities and
eccentricities and lovely little aspects
of life that give us enjoyment will be
stripped bare but at least no one will
be offended that's the world that
they're proposing and fortunately the
right offers an alternative I think this
is why the right is finally cool I think
this is why Kanye West now has produced
a t-shirt line for blacks it he got the
black exit this is why he's speaking and
so embracing the right is he says
there's dragon energy he says you know
there's masculine energy there's this
that whatever what he's really saying is
it's enjoyable it's nice Jerry Seinfeld
is no right winger he is far from a
right winger but you hear him a sailing
political correctness because it's just
not funny it's just awful it's so
terrible so I think this is an important
message
I'm really sorry The Simpsons caved on
this I mean I also don't care
I haven't watched it in 20 years I hope
that the rest of the culture realizes
this is a loser issue this is a loser
don't I know it seems like the screaming
[ __ ] I know it seems like there are a
lot of them there aren't there like five
of them who cares what they think
they'll toughen up they'll get it and
they'll grow out of it alright that's
our show we're at a time I'm even
running late check it out tonight we're
gonna be back 8:30 Eastern 5:30 Pacific
7:30 central on how to write nothing and
sell 100,000 copies I know that you lost
Mega Millions last week unless the
unless the winners are actually
listening to this show in which case you
should call me but if you're not you'll
need to you'll need to figure out how to
write nothing and sell a hundred
thousand copies that'll be tonight
University of Alabama Huntsville I'll be
back in the studio tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you later
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018